hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
fox news sunday host chris wallace joins
host chris foster to discuss
america's ongoing effort to continue the
2020 campaign
and recent developments regarding the
russia probe
also today marks the 75th anniversary of
ve day
host jessica rosenthal speaks with two
historians about how the allies victory
in europe
changed the course of history and the
parallels between world war ii
and the current global health crisis
plus commentary from former white house
speechwriter
and fox news contributor mark thiessen
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to fox news podcast dot com
maria bartoramo i'm greg gutfeld
i'm liz clayman and this is the fox news
rundown
friday may 8 2020 i'm chris foster fox
news sunday host chris wallace says
about president trump wanting to restart
the economy and move past the
coronavirus outbreak
you can't spin a disease it's either
going to get worse or it's not going to
get worse and we're going to find out
i'm jessica rosenthal it's been 75 years
since germany surrendered in world war
ii
ve day or victory in europe day was as
much a celebration for the military
as it was for everyone else first war in
history where civilian casualties are
greater than
military casualties you know everyone in
every country
had a price to pay and i'm mark thiessen
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
it's the end of another week with
millions more layoffs reported but also
a week with a lot more coronavirus
restrictions eased or ended
in some states it's golf and parks and
beaches reopened and summits hair salons
more retail even if it's just curbside
pickup in some places employees and
customers are wearing masks and
no one's allowing large gatherings yet
it's a long way from normal but a little
bit closer to it and president trump
tells fox
at some point we have to open our
country and
people are going to be safe we've
learned a lot we've learned about the
tremendous contagion
but we have no choice we have to we
can't stay closed as a country we're not
going to have a country left
a lot of americans just want to get back
to work and the president would like to
change the coronavirus conversation to a
message of recovery
here's what isn't changing is the the
spread of the virus
because while it is going down and they
have bent the curve
in new york state in fact it's
continuing to go up or at least plateau
in the rest of the country chris wallace
is the host of fox news sunday
we continue to have 25 000 new cases
of the virus every day and for the last
two days
we've had more than 2 000 deaths so
you know so many things we talk about
you know how
how do you feel about immigration or
something like that it's an opinion
and you know there's no settling of it
in the end there's
there will be a fact here it would be a
huge fact which is
that the the trump administration
and the governors most of the governors
including a lot of democrats not
and almost all the republicans are
reopening the country
and and reducing the barriers and either
it's gonna be okay and we're not gonna
see a huge spike in cases
uh as the administration is saying and
some of the governors are saying
or it's not and we're gonna as a lot of
the public health experts are saying and
we're gonna see a big spike because we
have not
reduced the number of cases enough we
don't have enough testing we don't have
enough contact raising
it you know it does you can't spin
a disease it's either going to get worse
or it's not going to get worse and we're
going to find out
you can maybe spin away there's talk of
oh they're over counting the deaths when
the truth is they're probably under
reporting the deaths but people are
saying oh they had an underlying
condition they really died of a heart
attack
they're calling it a covet death uh okay
maybe you can handle away ten percent of
them but it's still going to be a lot of
yeah you can you can say that but i i
i've seen now that the the white house
supposedly is gonna say that the
count is too high i think that's a
really
bad argument i just think you know
well it's not two thousand who died
today it was only sixteen hundred
only sixteen hundred i mean it's just
right it's uh
i just don't think that's a winning
argument people look people
are gonna know either either the the
virus is going to get better or it's not
either it's going to be safe to return
or it's not
if the facts are going to be obvious
you'll be able to see it on the on
in hospitals you'll be able to see it in
in stores in
uh and and things like that and the
other question is you know in the end
it isn't just the governors and the
president and even the store owners
who get a vote it's it's all of us you
know
are we are are your listeners out there
each one of you
are you going to feel safe going back to
a restaurant or not you're going to feel
safe getting on an airplane
or going to a store um you know each of
us is going to have to make that
decision ourselves and
you can open up everything but if people
don't feel comfortable doing it
uh the the economy is not going to
rebound
and with these restrictions let's say
you open
a restaurant at 50 capacity is that
going to be enough to bother keeping the
lights on
and well that's that or be able to keep
the restaurant i mean whether you
you know at 50 capacity and i think
that's extremely optimistic
because that's you know like we reduce
the the number of tables to
put them six feet away and every and
every table is
that we have is filled you know i don't
think that's gonna at least
according to the polls 70 80 percent of
people say
for instance in a case of a restaurant
i'm you know i would not feel
comfortable
going to a restaurant now that's what
what the polls are
the polls also indicate that democrats
are more worried about the disease than
republicans i wonder if those
republicans will
it's one thing to tell a pollster that i
wonder if they're actually going to go
to those restaurants and go to those
movie theaters
uh yeah you know i mean that's good i
agree it's going to be
again i you know i just keep saying you
can't spin
a disease it's it you know it's an it's
a
an act of god it's a fact of life it's a
natural phenomenon
and uh you know it doesn't matter
whether you're a liberal or conservative
you can get just as sick so maybe this
really doesn't happen until we have
immunity tests or a really good
treatment or
you know a vaccine best case scenario is
the end of the year
maybe maybe we just lived in this
half-assed life until then
i um i certainly agree that that the
vaccine is a huge thing
you know again i don't know anything
about this all i know people are talking
the end of the year and maybe with our
technology and our biotechnology and all
of that
we'll be able to do it but you read the
history of vaccines
and i don't know that any of them have
ever been invented
created tested safely and
scaled up so they can be given to
millions of people in
what would essentially be about six
eight months that's that would be
i hope it happens you know you you know
we can all pray for that
uh it's that would be quite an
achievement
well businesses are supposed to be
getting the help they need to weather
this
without you know having the freedom to
reopen i don't know what's happening
with those promises and then next we're
going to have this fight over aid to the
states who are trying to avoid their own
layoffs
well that's right and and i was talking
to a small businessman
uh in dc the other day and i asked him
about whether he had gotten
the ppp money the paycheck uh protection
program money
and he said i he had gotten it but he's
not sure he's going to use it and he may
give it back and i said why
and he said well dc's in a different
situation dc
they are still under a lockdown and
there's a lot of thought it might
continue
until the end of june and he
says the problem is that this ppp money
runs out in early june
and if i have to keep everybody you know
bring them back but now i've got to keep
them till the end of june
in uh on you know in full payment i
i'll go i'll go bankrupt on that because
i won't have any support
so you may have to see a another bridge
loan for the ppp
to keep in places that aren't reopening
to keep people
uh you know that are that are under the
system
uh solvent so that they don't go
bankrupt i mean this is
really complicated and uh you know i
fully understand the desire of the
president governors and it's going to be
by this weekend 43 governors who will
have either
opened all or part of their state i
understand the desire
to to move on but again you can't spend
a disease since we last spoke joe biden
has publicly addressed the tara reid
sexual assault allegation but he hasn't
made it go
away uh there's talk on both sides that
maybe he won't be the nominee i don't
see how that happens logistically
barring some crazy medical thing
i agree with you uh you know i was who
was i guess i saw
um bill bennett on on
television saying he thinks it's 50
percent chance
that uh that biden isn't going to be the
nominee i would i would take that path
uh you know is it conceivable sure you
can always write scenarios for anything
but uh there doesn't seem to be i mean
the thing that's most striking to me
about the whole biden power read thing
is that uh you know for all their talk
and you know there's clear hypocrisy
here on the part of democrats clear
double standard
where they jumped on christine blasey
ford's accusations
against uh brett kavanaugh you know here
they're saying well yeah we heard her
and we
heard what he's denied it and we're
going with joe you know so if it's
somebody they like
they they they'll they'll hear the uh
the accuser but they're not going to
believe the accuser also this week
house republicans have been pushing for
the release of now declassified
transcripts of interviews during the
russia election meddling investigation
claiming house intelligence committee
chairman adam schiff has been blocking
that
the fact that republicans are pushing so
hard for it the fact that rick grinnell
who's a very politically connected guy
very much in the trump team and he's now
the acting director of national
intelligence is pushing
to uh release these transcripts these
are as i understand it these are the
transcripts of the
of the hearings that were held when the
republicans were in charge of the house
intel committee
back between 2017 and and 20
2017 and 18 those two years before adam
schiff took over but chef now has been
trying to stop them from being turned
over
and and one of the things is that that
chief came out
after these hearings and said well
there's hard evidence here in these in
these closed
top secret or classified hearings that
there was collusion between the
president
uh and uh and the russians
and you know the the implication seems
to be if the republicans want to put
them out it's going to show
that there was no evidence of collusion
and trump uh
you know and schiff was just spinning a
tail i don't know
i mean if you like donald trump you
already hate adam schiff if you hate
donald trump you already like adam chip
whether it's going to change a lot of
minds or not i don't know but you know
it's always interesting to see whether
somebody had backup for what he was
saying at the time sure
all right chris wallace what has become
our weekly chat
the host of fox news sunday here on the
fox news rundown chris hopefully we'll
do it again next week good to talk to
you
you bet thank you chris
[Music]
this is mark thiessen with your fox news
commentary coming up
today is the 75th anniversary of ve day
or victory in europe day
the german surrender in world war ii
came almost immediately after adolf
hitler
killed himself throughout the world
throngs of people hail the end of the
war in europe
it is five years and more since hitler
marched into poland
a war in which more civilians were
killed than soldiers
so victory was not just for the military
britain
ken haye fought in normandy alongside
his brother
he remembers celebrating ve day in the
evening somebody some girls called out
hey soldier give us a kiss all the women
were sort of coming around kissing
i never had so many kisses it never had
since everybody was
coming up and kissing and well done and
shaking hands and so on
it was a very joyous moment but up until
ve day
things were precarious the germans were
looking for an alternative to surrender
but there was really nowhere for them to
go as one of our podcast guests put it
the luftwaffe was destroyed the navy was
stuck in port the british and americans
were on the elb
and the russians were in berlin it was
over
well this part was over the europe part
well there are two things i think people
forget when they think about v day
first point is it wasn't really the end
of the war
sal david is professor of military
history at the university of buckingham
of course it was the end of the war in
europe and that had been raging since
1939 but there was an awful lot of
fighting that carried on actually
interestingly in europe
and of course far more significantly
than that there was a war still going on
in the pacific and until that was one
the second world war would not be over
japan of course had started the war in
in america by the pearl harbor um action
and and therefore emotionally i think
americans were much more closely tuned
into what was going on in the pacific
than they were in europe right
tell me um tell me though you you are
british as we know
and this uh you know this isn't in the
distant history do you have any
personal knowledge of
ve day whether that's through relatives
or
older folks in in your own life growing
up in in britain that you may have
talked to or have known that you can
i guess share with us yeah i mean
interestingly enough my
my own mother um who's half american
actually and although she was born in
britain
and brought up in britain and was in
britain for part of the war she'd
actually come over to america by the end
of the war and she said something quite
interesting to me which is that during
ve day um there was there was of course
a famous speech by churchill in which he
talks about you know the extraordinary
long
years of hardship and then uh first
russia coming in on the side of the
allies and then the americans and then
finally they managed to defeat
uh this you know the terrible demon of
germany she said she actually
listened to that broadcast churchill
giving that broadcast in america because
of course her parents were
my father was american her mother was
english and and they were interested in
what was going on in europe and
and she said it was incredibly emotional
moment to hear
that finally the war in europe was over
this was a war in which far more
civilians
died than members of the military right
i mean so celebration of a victory here
takes on
really different meaning this war seems
like it was so impactful
to really everyone your your mother
included what was
life like for civilians across europe
for these
five almost six years well they talk
about the first world wars the first
total war but you're you're absolutely
right the second world war was the first
time
whole populations mainly because of air
power of course in the use of bombs
but whole populations were really
dragged in not not only into the war
effort that had happened in the first
world war but into the danger of war
and of course the the terrible end game
is the is the huge casualties
first war in history where civilian
casualties are greater than
um uh military casualties you know
everyone in every country had a had a
price to pay
over the years these sort of like
hindsight think pieces about
you know how this war maybe could have
been different maybe even shorter
have been written i what in your mind
were some of the
allies missed opportunities or snafus
and i was watching as you know as i've
already told you the greatest events of
world war ii in color on netflix
and i watched one historian say that you
know he nearly lost his mind
when allied forces failed to do the
reconnaissance
that would have shown them like a line
of german tanks and soldiers
waiting to push in to france i don't
know if i'm recalling that correctly
but he he became so he said he becomes
sort of unglued thinking about that sort
of missed opportunity to take out
all of those uh german forces
and and soldiers what comes to your mind
i think one of the biggest debates has
been whether or not
uh the allies should have invaded
western europe earlier and in that
particular debate
i'm very much on the side of no it was
right to wait there was an original plan
to go in 42
then in 43 a lot of pressure from the
russians of course because they wanted a
second front to be opened
uh to take the pressure off them but i
think the allies were absolutely right
to wait until
1944. even in 44 the germans
in france and in western europe were a
very formidable opposition
and if they hadn't waited you if if i
turn your question around and look at it
from a slightly different perspective if
they had gone in in 43
it could have been an absolute disaster
and that could have extended the war by
a year or two
but what about germany professor and
director of the military history center
at the university of north texas
jeffrey warrow explains the germans had
big plans after
world war one to create a new army
though the terms
ending world war one limited that new
army they eventually ignored those rules
they created new weapons equipment and
tanks
but after the blitzkrieg and germany's
rapid expansion taking over multiple
countries
a lot of things did not go as well as
they'd hoped and really for the germans
the uh
you know the the fatal flaws that hitler
is
in ideologue you know and he he doesn't
sort of respond to rational strategic
calculus and he doesn't realize that
he's got a perfectly good non-aggression
pact with the soviet union
he ought to leave that in place
consolidate his victories in the west
instead
in 1941 he had taxed the soviet union
and brings on this war of attrition with
the soviets that's bound to wear the
germans down
and then on on on pearl harbor day he
compounds that error by you know almost
gratuitously declaring war on the united
states
to kind of buck up japan and encourage
it to fight
you know harder so that brings the us
which might have confined its operations
to the pacific
into the european war so now you've got
you've got basically the germans not
only you know they've
beaten western europe they've chased the
british back onto the british isles
uh they're in a very strong position but
then he throws it all away by attacking
the soviet union
and declaring war on the united states
um talk to me about the the civilians
millions of civilians have died and in
my lifetime when we've had war
we've talked about this need to to of
course preserve civilian life to
not go after civilians to to make every
effort
you know not to hurt civilians that that
was so
not the case in world war two the
germans basically had a genocidal
uh campaign in the east they wanted to
basically remove
the inhabitants of the east and open
that space up you know the whole space
from
eastern germany um you know east into
the soviet union and they wanted to
take over everything up to the urals
mountains
as as a sort of a ground for german
settlers so
they wanted to get rid of everybody
there they wanted to you know and they
wanted to
kill all the jews the jews you know the
bulk of the jews in europe were living
in poland
that's why paul if you look at the you
know poland has these massive civilian
casualties
because the you know this the entire
jewish population of the soviet union
living in the old tale of settlement in
poland and belarus and ukraine all the
all of the all of these people were
rounded up and and uh
initially exterminated by firing squads
and then as when these
big death camps like auschwitz and
treblinka toby boar came
online they were then they were then
moved into these camps
and and uh and killed and um
so that's you know that's why you see
all these casualties and then plus five
million
you know red army prisoners taken by
these germans by the germans in these
big battles of encirclement at the
beginning of the war
um they're all killed either starved to
death or left
and die of hypothermia or killed in the
death camps themselves
you know because of the nazi program of
genocide because of this
desperate japanese attempt to use terror
to you know cow the chinese population
you do see these massive
you know unprecedentedly huge civilian
losses
and ending those civilian losses is of
course a huge cause for celebration
um as ve day was despite the continued
war with japan for another few months
but
but it was the beginning of a huge i
mean huge giant
massive undertaking to heal with the
marshall plan and of course you know the
the division of germany
it's hard to underestimate just how much
this war
changed everything and still impacts us
today
you know our relationship with countries
the borders of countries right i mean
it's
it's still it it either haunts us or
it's contributing
to to how we operate oh absolutely i
mean uh
when the when the war ends you've got uh
you know really hard choices at yalta
you know uh
these these big uh wartime summits
between the big three
churchill roosevelt stalin stalin
not only does he want you know sort of
the spoils of war but he wants security
and so
he he he fears a resurgence of germany
so he wants kind of a cordon of states
in the east like
you know basically the central european
and balkan states he wants those
in soviet hands um under you know soviet
satellite states so he can have this
kind of physical barrier between
the soviet union and germany for the
future but he also wants to control that
space uh to
to magnify soviet power in europe
there's just a lot of acrimony after the
war
about what happened you know there's
that famous scene in the movie patton
where
you know they're sort of partying after
after ve day and patton's like okay you
know on to moscow
now we have to beat the real enemy the
soviets you know
uh but patton's like a you know a lonely
voice everybody is just so
exhausted by the war and so relieve this
over that there's just no chance that
you know the united states is going to
now invade the soviet union and try to
topple stalin
when basically everybody in the united
states
written everywhere soviet union they
wanted to get back to normalcy they
wanted a peace dividend
and they wanted just to enjoy the the
fruits of peace after these like
you know horrific years of war getting
back to normalcy
sound familiar we keep hearing that now
as some of us isolate due to the virus
as others battle illness and others lose
their jobs
professor saul david sees the parallels
you know they i don't think actually the
you know the so-called war
on the virus is is overdone it's you
know it's not it's not a literal war in
which we're using arm you know we're
using weapons to defeat it but we are
all coming together as a nation i think
i think they've been some very positive
uh actions in the uk in which the whole
country
has had to behave in a certain way for
the greater good
and there's no that is no bad thing in
that and there's certainly you can see
comparisons with the second world war
and if i just go back to you know making
the point about
1945 not being an endgame
at veda because they were still fighting
to to to continue
you very very much get a sense of this
togetherness
you know both truman and churchill are
talking about
carrying on the war um the job is only
half done we need to defeat the japanese
now
and so you get a sense today yes it's
not a similar type of war but to bring
everyone together in a common purpose i
actually think positive things will come
out of this
god willing uh professor sal david thank
you so much for your time
thank you
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
almost 50 years ago dennis runke was a
student
at kansas state university when his
father died suddenly
forcing him to leave school just two
credits shy of his degree
in recent weeks runkey has become known
to america through a letter he sent to
new york governor andrew cuomo
who read it last month during a daily
covid 19 briefing
i'm a retired farmer hunkered down
in northeast kansas with my wife
who has but one lung runkey had been
watching the virus take lives in the hot
spot of new york
and he had five n95 masks left over from
his farmwork in kansas
he kept four for his family and sent the
other one to the governor
would you please give this mask to a
nurse
or doctor in your state his actions went
viral
and the washington post reports that
when kansas governor laura kelly learned
of it
she asked kansas state university
president richard myers if runke could
be awarded an honorary
degree myers said runkey's decades of
farm work were enough
to make up for the two credits and gave
him the real thing
this week runkey got his bachelor's
degree at a special ceremony
and in his address he said he's heard
from a lot of people following his viral
moment
many of those who wrote to me to thank
me
asked me how they could help
just pay it forward as much as you can
afford to do so
to honor all those who have lost their
lives
to the c-19 virus
and also to honor the first responders
who in
some cases even lost their own lives
in the line of duty
the ultimate sacrifice his mailing the
mask
has inspired others nearly half of the
many letters i received said that they
were
moved to tears when governor cuomo read
my letter
aloud my life has forever
changed one act of kindness with a
national ripple effect
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind president trump said
this weekend that we should
have a vaccine for covet 19 by the end
of this year we all hope he's right
america is the can-do nation with the
most dynamic innovative economy in human
history
so most americans just assume that we're
going to be able to have an effective
treatment available
in a couple of months and a vaccine not
far behind but what if we don't
trump administration has launched
operation warp speed
a manhattan project style effort to
deliver a vaccine with 300 million doses
by january
the president is to be commended for
pressing his foot on the accelerator
and clearing bureaucratic obstacles to
vaccine development
but like putting a man on the moon he's
asking us scientists to do something
that has
never been done before consider the
biopharmaceutical industry has been
working on developing a vaccine for hiv
for almost 40 years without success
we still don't have a cure for the
common cold some colds are caused by a
coronavirus
in fact we have never developed a
vaccine for a coronavirus before
and it took almost five years to produce
a vaccine for ebola
the fastest a vaccine has ever been
developed for a dangerous new virus
to meet trump's stated goal we would
have to more than quintuple
that record there are now about 95
vaccines for this virus under
development
the vast majority will fail others may
actually make it easier to catch the
virus
or they may worsen the disease which has
happened with some hiv drugs
dr scott gottlieb former commissioner of
the food and drug administration says
there are very few settings in medicine
where you have the potential with a
medical product to cause distributed
harm mass casualties
it's not a vaccine you're going to give
to 10 000 people or 10 million people
it's a vaccine you're going to give to
the entire world
and if it has some latent side effect
that isn't apparent for many months and
many years and you've just given it to
100 million people
you can cause serious harm over a very
large population unquote
gottlieb says we ha we will have a
vaccine in large clinical trials by the
fall
but the more likely path out of today's
lockdown is the development of an
effective therapeutic
coupled with a very robust surveillance
system that allows us to ring fence
small outbreaks before they become
large outbreaks but finding even one
effective treatment is also incredibly
hard
the most promising therapy under
investigation is remdessevere
which was recently approved for
emergency use in severely ill covid19
patients
a preliminary study found the drug
improved recovery time
from 15 days to 11 days a 31
decrease and showed no statistically
significant
effect on mortality avik roy healthcare
expert
says the best that can be said about
that drug is it shortens your hospital
stay by a couple of days
it's not a cure it's a modest
improvement on the condition unquote
now that's not what most people have in
mind when they think of a therapeutic
they want something that treats their
illness quickly and sends them back into
the world
but the reality is we may not have that
kind of treatment for some time much
less
a vaccine that confers immunity so what
do we do
roy argues that we may have to restart
the economy before we have completely
controlled the pandemic
reopening schools and businesses for
lower risk individuals
and using contact tracing to slow the
spread of the virus
he points out that about a hundred
thousand people die every year in the
united states from hospital-born
infections
yet we don't shut down the entire
hospital industry
he says quote think of all the people
who aren't seeking health care for
non-coveted illnesses how many of those
people are going to die prematurely
because they didn't get the health care
they should have gotten in a normal
environment
we've just thrown 30 million people out
of their jobs how many deaths of despair
are we going to have
take place because of the wreckage we've
imposed on the economy unquote
the search for a vaccine is a moonshot
and it may work after all
america is the nation that put a man on
the moon but we can't keep the economy
in lockdown while we wait
the purpose of the lockdown was not to
prevent every american from getting
covet 19
but to prevent our health care system
from being overwhelmed
roy says we've done that it's time to
stop annihilating the economy
i'm mark thiessen
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion
you trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes